what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course right now all we can talk about
is doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness that trailer dropped right
before the super bowl and they teased us
with patrick stewart returning as
professor xavier and they gave us a full
shot although vague but a full shot of
the illuminati we see all of their
chairs there and we see doctor strange
brought in for judgment against a
multiversal illuminati and this is
really exciting but a lot of people are
actually failing to realize what a
particular scene in this trailer
actually is which is the scarlet witch
fighting the illuminati and i personally
think that the members of the illuminati
that go up against the scarlet witch are
going to die i don't think they're going
to be able to defeat wanda and i think
they're all going to go up against her
so let's talk about this and big thank
you to extra for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit and if you love
marvel be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos now
right now we don't know who all of the
official members of the illuminati are
going to be in multiverse of madness
however we can assume that these are
going to be some of the strongest heroes
across the multiverse not only is this
an illuminati team which always consists
of the strongest heroes and leaders of
each group iron man from the avengers
black bolt from the inhumans professor x
from the x-men mr fantastic of the
fantastic four neymar the submariner of
atlantis and of course doctor strange
all extremely powerful characters now we
can assume a multiversal illuminati is
going to have even greater characters
the best of the best from their
respective universes now we have the
iron legion ultron bot so we can assume
that superior iron man is in the
illuminati even if he's not in the
trailer even if that wasn't him if it
was maria rambo as captain marvel or
maybe it was iron lad because it kind of
looks like king that doesn't really
matter at this point because the ultron
bots give away that superior iron man is
in the film so superior iron man
professor xavier of course one of the
strongest mutants out there probably
captain carter as we see her shield in
the poster for multiverse of madness a
lot of us are assuming mr fantastic will
be a part of the illuminati since he is
a part of the original illuminati and
rumors have been going around about
somebody possibly playing him hint john
krasinski we don't know if that's
confirmed or not right now that's just
what the fans want but maybe a mr
fantastic who is also extremely powerful
probably a variant of doctor strange or
maybe mordo is the person as the
sorcerer supreme on the council and what
looks to be perhaps balder the brave or
maybe century that big person on the
right sitting down in the chair with the
long hair and i do believe maria rambo
as captain marvel will be in this film
as well and sadly i think all of these
people are going to die in the scene in
the trailer we actually see somebody
attacking the scarlet witch it looks
like they come at her full force as well
again whether this is superior iron man
or captain marvel that's a lot of force
whoever it is and wanda defends herself
very very well and blocks whatever
attack is coming at her also if you
notice the background we can see statues
with wings on them these same statues
are found in the courtyard that doctor
strange is escorted through by the
ultron bots as he makes his way to the
headquarters of the illuminati's council
room so that confirms that this takes
place inside of the illuminati's
headquarters wanda is fighting the
illuminati now the illuminati are going
to go up against wanda and this probably
is not the end of the film this is
probably somewhere in the middle so we
know they're not going to defeat wanda
because that would kind of end the story
wanda is probably not going to be
defeated until the very end of the film
whether that's her coming to her senses
and realizing that she's been evil or
somebody actually defeats her so since
wanda isn't going to be defeated in the
scene we can assume she is going to be
the one defeating the illuminati now at
this point it looks like wanda truly is
kind of getting evil she has learned
from the darkhold which is an evil book
full of dark magic and dark spells which
she has now learned and might even be a
little bit possessed by the maker of the
darkhold the ancient evil elder god
c'thun so if you put all of that
together not only is she the scarlet
witch in which only one should exist in
even all of the multiverses she has all
of the power and knowledge of the
darkhold now and could be a little bit
possessed by an evil elder god this
makes her insanely dangerous and what is
she looking for her kids this is a huge
motivating factor in wanda's journey
across multiverse of madness she is
going through the multiverse in search
for her children they were taken away
from her along with vision and now she's
had it she's the ultimate powerful being
in the multiverse and she's gonna stop
at nothing to get her kids back and if
anybody gets in her way she's going to
take care of them she will not let them
get in her way and unfortunately that
means the illuminati and again what i'm
about to talk about is i think they're
all going to die so it does look like
either superior iron man or captain
marvel who is going to be a maria rambo
version of captain marvel is going to
attack first maybe it isn't her that
attacks first trailers can of course be
misleading intentionally but we do know
that they indeed fight and if this is
captain marvel i actually think it's
very clever because there is somewhat of
a debate between who would win in a
fight the scarlet witch or captain
marvel to me i think scarlet witch wins
no problem especially now with magic
that she knows from the darkhold she now
knows that she is the scarlet witch and
she has magic in herself not just powers
given to her from an infinity stone but
has actual magic so she would have
mastered that already using the darkhold
and just time so she is going to tear
through captain marvel from there she's
probably going to start to take out the
rest of the illuminati i'm assuming she
probably catches one off guard and
attacks really really quickly either
this is the very beginning of the battle
and she initiates it by killing one very
very quickly or she gets attacked and
after she defeats the first person
attacks the second very quickly and they
die now from here obviously the others
would step in but let's not forget that
doctor strange is there too and we have
seen a scene of mordo attacking doctor
strange while he is in those handcuffs
again another clear sign of evidence
that a fight breaks out here in the
illuminati headquarters but it looks
like the illuminati are also fighting
doctor strange so not all of the
illuminati at once are going to attack
wanda and as much as i hate to say it i
do think everybody dies because next up
would be captain carter and i love
captain carter she's awesome i can't
wait to see her live action but she
doesn't stand a chance against wanda mr
fantastic is one of my favorite
characters ever because of his intellect
but unfortunately power wise i don't
think he stands much of a chance against
wanda either and if mordo is really the
sorcerer supreme of his universe and he
is a member of the illuminati it looks
like he's going to be fighting doctor
strange he might be the only one that
survives but that's really going to be
up to wanda now as much as i hate to say
it up next is professor xavier and i
think that she's going to kill him too
and it makes you wonder how many times
do we have to watch this guy die on
screen apparently not enough because i
do believe we are going to see him die
one more time yes he is very very
powerful and yes his telepathy is an
omega class but he himself is an alpha
level mutant but his telepathy is going
to go up against wanda's chaos magic
which as of right now is kind of
undefinable however like i said we know
she's going to be filled with rage
filled with knowledge of the darkhold
and is willing to do anything to get her
kids back this makes for a pretty
unstoppable force and judging by this
shot of wanda that we get where there's
blood all over her face this looks like
it's a final blow a final blow to the
last member of the illuminati standing
who i believe is sadly going to be
professor xavier or mordo mordo might
live we'll have to see but this shot
indicates that a massive fight has taken
place and the fact that we have two
other scenes where the illuminati is
fighting means that yes there is going
to be a huge fight here and i believe
wanda is coming out on top and everybody
else will die but what do you think do
you think anybody is going to be capable
of stopping the scarlet witch do you
think some of them will make it out
alive by running away or do you think
the illuminati could defeat her let me
know what you think about this theory in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you